I forgot I made the screen nice.
Are you regretting it?
No, I'm not.
Yeah, she's gonna eat me.
She's gonna eat you?
Yeah, so Ashton is the meal on the table and Barry's like,
er, waiter?
What am I doing?
Waiter, more, more, more, more.
I got the Mimi chair.
No, you're like, I'll have what she's having.
No, but you're next up because she's like, waiter, more
rodent, please.
More rodent, please.
Hi everybody!
Hello!
This is gonna be the most annoying collab.
We're already like, we're like super, we're super silly
guys.
Oh, let's do introduction.
Uh, Ashton.
This got so formal.
Hi, my name is Ashton Martin.
Wait, I don't have an intro.
No, you don't have to do it.
Let me know.
Well, this is some of your, well, Ashton, I've collabed with
you, but you...
But no, it wasn't on my channel either.
So I don't think it's, yeah, I don't think people, yeah,
you've never been on my channel.
It's my first time with the, I, the booboos.
Yes!
I got there, I got there, I got there.
Hello everybody, my name is Ashley Martin.
I'm the roller rodent race queen and.
She's on the table.
Because I'm a snack.
Ew.
Hello, hello, hello.
Alright, you're next.
Hi everyone, I'm Viviana and I'm a mouse.
I don't have an intro.
I'm a mouse, squeak!
Squeak!
I'm passing around the mic.
It's like open mic night.
Hey guys, welcome to the laugh factory.
Well, what's the deal with airplane food?
Hi, everyone.
My name is Barry and I'm a bug.
And you guys might not know the last member.
My, my, ba!
Do it!
No, everybody's laughing at me.
I'm going home.
Get out of my room.
I'm going to bed.
Yay!
She said the thing.
It's my channel!
I hope you guys know who I am.
Maybe don't.
I'm a phantom.
You haven't heard.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't know me.
I introduced myself to someone tonight and he didn't know
who I was.
So I was like, wow.
And you're meet and greet today?
No.
Oh, actually there were some people that came and they were
like, I've never watched any of you at all.
I like how people do that and they're like, all right, give
me the elevator pitch.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're going to have to set aside 30 minutes for this to go.
I know.
First we got to start with there's this thing on YouTube
called The Annoying Orange.
We're going, it's like, Do you have to give a whole history
to elevator pitch?
Yeah.
Wait, okay, elevator pitch isn't.
Wait, no!
No, you're just as bad as that.
Ashton, I'm new to VTubers.
Can you explain why I should watch you?
You fucking...
Do you like cars?
Why are you putting me on the hotspot, man?
What's your favorite car?
Personally, my favorite car is...
Well, no, hey, well, actually, I do have a favorite car.
It's a white Ford Bronco.
And I'm dead serious about that.
I'm really not, I have no idea why you guys are laughing.
Because, I'm turning the audience.
Sure, I have no idea why you guys are laughing.
I mean, I went with 100% seriousness.
God.
You're so funny, you're like smiling, like a big old grin at
you.
Well, now I know what that means.
Why is an O.J.
Simpson car.
Why?
Yeah.
Because he ran away.
Dude, because that's his car.
It is.
Well, because I always want to.
That was a movie.
Dude, that's his car.
oh you're really showing your
you know oj simpson had a whiteboard bronco it was like you
know the juice is loose the juice oh wow we got to start at
the beginning so there's okay but there was the vtuber named
annoying orange
Wait a second, I never thought of that.
We're giving you new material.
Whoa, I'm going to write this down for my stand-up.
Wait a second.
Has anybody looked into this?
Yay!
We're going to do karaoke, but don't expect anything good.
So, what do you guys want to sing?
Or also, our voices are like, so dead, everybody.
It's girls' night.
We're just goofing around.
It's girls' night at the end.
the cafe.
It is, it is.
Why am I on my side?
I'm just, why am I on my side?
And I'm just, and I'm licking my lips, too.
Because you know you're a snack.
Oh, you're repeating my own jump accident.
You said that earlier?
Yeah, I did.
It's okay.
It's not funny what I'm saying.
Mouse eater.
Oh, snake eater.
What do you eat?
Yeah, the thumbnail, the thumbnail.
We drew the thumbnail.
Oh yeah.
We did try.
So, wait, who drew?
You, you.
I drew mint.
The Mimi drew mint.
Yeah.
And then I drew the Mimi.
And then and then Ashton.
Yeah.
True.
Very.
Wait, okay.
She drew me normally.
With a really big head.
Which I mean.
Mint drew Ashton.
Look at your screen folks.
No, shut up.
Shut up.
Look at your screen folks.
I'm being accused of drawing Barry with a that's much too
large okay fine I'll make you smaller where are you I have
such a big girl let's not throw hey hey hey hey okay and
then and then I drew yeah wait I drew Ashton.
And then also added blood to my mouth.
Because they said that I drew Ashton Ugly.
Well, I know the orange was a good addition.
Gamer a hunchback.
Is that how you see me?
I mean, I'm looking at you.
I don't want to hear that from you.
I have Gamer Poster.
Miss Gamer Poster.
I know.
We're all bad.
We're all shrimping.
It doesn't help because I have such like a long tour.
because I'm part Martin you must understand I'm like I'm
like 70% torso man so like I have a lot to hunch I get it oh
like the cars they have that who like roof you know the roof
hump yes I don't know should we sing a song yes Disney a
Disney song.
Yeah.
What's Disney song?
Oh, God.
Do you know at last I see the light?
Why are we- That's so, like, sad.
Yeah, yeah, let's do high energy.
Do you like, it's a small world or something?
I want to drone on the entire time.
What's a fun Disney song?
Are we blaming about that?
There's, like, so many.
I know.
There's too many that it's like...
I know, I'm like...
Becoming hard.
know it's like a memeish well aren't like most of the songs
they're kind of a lot of ballads yeah we can do hellfire
from the i thought that was true i was like oh yeah that
one's crazy you are on the special effects you are default
that's a favorite part
uh sure we'll do hellfire oh my god is batara here is she i
don't know i see people in chat isn't here whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa and i'm mad about it i know matari we're supposed
to be here matara she's in chat oh she is matara i don't see
you she's like purposely looking away oh oh oh oh oh i'm
gonna accidentally ban somebody and we probably should give
context to these uh oh it must be so odd watching just like
a static image i'm used to like i know like wiggling around
it's weird we gotta just describe if someone does something
something like something goofy yeah we need the play-by-play
yeah yeah like my Ashton inevitably tackles me off to a hey
where is she Matara gone I don't see you Matara send another
message yeah show us a sign where are you oh there she is
where is she did you ban her and now he can't read her any
messages oh no there we go oh okay Thank you.
Where is Bug?
Lips of an angel.
Oh, lips of an angel.
That's like Matara's song.
Oh, yeah.
Lips of an angel?
Yeah, she loves...
What song is that?
I'm gonna hear you, boy.
I'm, my, my, my, my, my, my.
Wait, I don't remember that song.
Is that your impression of Matara or the actual song?
The actual song.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's really like that.
He's just like, oh, no, I don't know.
You can mostly hear lips of an angel and like, nothing else.
It sounds like a biker boy.
bar song it is it's all about like NTR it's crazy I've
literally never heard the song when you said lips of an
angel first my my brain auto corrected to kiss is that also
like my girls in the next room is it that one oh my girls in
the next room I know that now I know that now
Thank you for providing the gems in context.
I was like, yeah, I gotta like translate for you.
Matara's dumb.
She's trying to time out, people.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my God.
I wonder, I'm trying to see if I can maybe like put it on
the ground, like the tower.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Wait, let's all sit on the ground.
Should I do?
Like a little table?
I can't tackle anybody on the ground.
Somebody at some point is gonna have to sit on the bed so I
can start tackling people.
Oh my God.
I'm gonna have like rodent on rodent violence.
Yeah.
Rodent on the bed.
Wait, wait, wait, let's do it.
I didn't tell me to get on the bed.
Get on the bed.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ah!
Oh my god, wait, why are you...
Oh my god.
She's like, what, Ashton?
She's like, actually doing wrestling.
Oh my god, Ashton is currently on top of Nimimiani and is...
Oh my god.
I don't know if I've ever liked that.
What's happening?
Barry, just a double, triple team nerd.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
What do you guys get out?
Oh my god, wait, why are we standing up?
Why are we standing up?
She's gonna soup like that.
Get German soup like that.
Oh my god, we're like a real girl supper party.
I'm gonna get a noise complaint.
I was actually just thinking about that.
Okay, let's calm down.
Yeah, we're calm, we're chill, we're calm, we're cool.
We're gonna sing Hellfire.
Does everyone know Hellfire?
I only want to do songs we all know.
I worry that I don't know it well enough, actually.
Okay, um, it's low Let's what's another fun Disney song.
I tried to get it.
I was like, this is too low.
It's a small world Hi-ho Well, there's like the Oh, Hi-ho is
cute, but I don't know if anybody knows me when I when I see
Where my life figure?
Oh, the Gaston song.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yes, yes.
Gaston who said who said that in chat?
No one sucks.
VIP that guy in chat.
Look good job.
Thank you.
Okay, we're singing it in French.
Okay, sounds good.
I can't do this.
Is this the freaking recent?
No, no, this is...
I don't know the beginning.
How's that?
I'm trying to
like- That guy's not that one.
I don't think it's that far.
It's not that far.
I'm gonna do that far.
I got Mimi.
I got Barry.
I got my eye.
What?
What are we doing?
We're gonna get suplexed later.
You only suplex me.
You did suplex Barry?
I don't- Well, she turned in the fight.
I'm just saying that like- Yeah, I- I was not- Why did you
guys like double see you?
Wait, wait, wait, hold on.
We're almost there, we're almost there.
Sorry guys, is it still loud?
I think it might be loud.
No one!
I don't know what I'm gonna wear.
No one, think about it.
I guess not.
Perfect if you're fair again.
Come to your family.
And they'll tell you whose teammate preferred it.
be us.
Oh, what the hell?
Spin like a star.
How can't be like a star?
No one's gotta smell clean like a star like a star.
There's a specimen.
Yeah, yeah, it doesn't.
I wanna die like a star.
It turns out we don't know the song.
Guess what?
What do we know?
All the rest is on...
DRIPS!
No.
In a wrestling match nobody bites like Ashton.
Why did she chop at me?
Oh my god.
Every inch of me is covered with hair.
No one hits nobody's face like Ashton.
Ashton!
Katie, patooie, patooie!
When I was a lad, I ate four dozen eggs every morning to
help me get large.
And now that I'm grown, I eat five dozen eggs, so I'm
roughly the size of a barge.
That was good.
She's really good.
Wow, it's really good.
We didn't even sing half the song.
I know.
I'm super successful.
Oh my god, everyone.
It's so loud.
Is that better, guys?
I know it's still loud, Ty.
And his name's T-A-S-T.
G-A-S-T-E.
This is me trying to spell your name earlier, Ashley.
And then there's a S-T-R-S-A.
Ashton Byton.
Ah-Ton Byton.
Make a man out of you.
That's what it's called?
I mean, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, it's all make a man out of you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one, ill, you gotta know that.
Make a mouse out of you.
Johnny Osmond.
Yeah, that's what we're going to do to you guys.
Wait, hello?
Wait, what?
What does that mean?
That's all we're gonna do to you guys.
I can't say.
Don't turn it to Sue.
I didn't have to say it yet.
Wait, I'm chasing it.
No, we know this one.
Let's get down to business to defeat Ashdod.
He said it every time.
Why?
You're so sad.
You're the saddest bunch I ever met.
But you can bet before we're through.
Mr. Howe, make a man out of you.
It's so low.
Crancliffe has a forest, but a fire with it.
your center you are sure to win you're a spider's pale
pathetic lot and you haven't gotten through somehow I'll
make a man out of you wait this has to be like one at a time
right the oh yeah I'm never gonna catch my breath say
goodbye to those who knew me who was my fool in school for a
couple This guy's got us scared to death!
Hope he doesn't save my Toby!
I really wish that I knew how to swim.
The ocean must be swift as the coursing river With all the
strength of a great typhoon With all the strength of a
raging fire Mysterious and the dark side of the moon I'm
like a puberty What?
I'm going to puberty, I'm cracking.
Do you need water?
Maybe.
Yeah, there's water right there.
All righty.
Wait, I don't know.
You need my every order and you might survive.
Go.
You're unsuited for the rage of war.
So pack up, go home.
You're through.
How could I make a man?
and out of you.
And then someone has to climb the pole.
You.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna go.
This is good.
I'm very sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to go.
I'm on HR.
The Arceus has the archival.
I know.
The moon.
I must be with the circle.
I know.
We are mad, it's all the force of a great typhoon.
We are mad, it's all the strength of a raging fire.
And that is our side of the moon!
Okay, now that we got a group song done, we can do solos.
Why are you saying, oh my god?
Is Mitara singing in chat?
I don't know.
I think she is.
I think she's like...
typing out the lyrics in chat.
Yeah, Matara!
Matara's solo, let's go!
Matara!
She has to sing the Megara song.
Lips of a... what?
Angel.
Lips of an angel.
No, like a Hercules, the...
Wait, that's a good one too.
Yeah, for Matara's voice too.
Which one?
Like because the raspy, like the Meg thing.
Oh, I love that song!
Wait, yeah.
It could be like the muses.
Oh, she's a...
Yeah!
That's perfect for you.
Do you mean Ursula?
No!
Oh my god!
Actually, what song does Ursula sing?
I tried singing that one on karaoke when I did it on
Thursday, but like, they don't give you the muses, so you
have to like rush to do both of them.
They do in this, Caravan.
Oh, do they!
Yeah, this app is crazy.
No, I don't want to walk in.
Yes!
Oh my goodness.
Don't knock down everything.
My throat hurts, man.
I know, me too.
You want some cough stuff?
It's actually over.
We're all getting sick after this.
Huh?
I don't think we're sick.
We've just been yelling and screaming.
That's very true, that's very true, that's very true.
We're all like, just like the stupidest shit, I'm like
accidentally rage baiting the group because I'm saying
stupid shit.
Oh my god.
There's like Barry saying, oh thank you, love is an open
door.
Oh yeah, alone.
Okay, okay.
But no one sings Hansparks.
That's what I did on stream, like it was just like dead
silent.
Okay, we'll do that, no one sings Hansparks.
What the hell?
Yeah, then somebody afterwards says, it again but with two
people yeah just to show you just to like actually put me in
the chair what the hell this is yeah i have to make sure i
turn the guy part off okay yeah he's not oh no guys you hate
me wait was this not sound good wait sorry was this not
sound good was this not sound good okay can i just say
something crazy am i alone yeah oh oh my life has been a
series of doors in my face And then suddenly I bump into
you.
I was thinking the same thing because like, I've been
searching my whole life to find my own place.
And maybe it's the party talking.
Oh, I don't know this.
Or the chocolate fondue.
Come with you.
With you.
I found my place.
I see your face.
And it's nothing like I've ever known before.
Love is an open car.
Door!
Loves an open.
With you!
Loves an open door!
And then we start making out.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait a second.
I mean, it's crazy.
What?
We finish each other's...
That's what I was gonna say!
No, thanks so much like me.
Jinks!
Jinks again!
Our mental secret!
I have a one explanation you you and I were just meant to be
She's drawing hearts over us Oh anyone Was it open?
Love can be so much more with you You!
You!
Not almond doll.
Or...
I'm so sorry.
No, why do you do this alone?
I was gonna help you!
You're being so mean.
I'm sorry.
If we get a noise complaint, I'll just show myself out.
I gotta go, y'all.
Guys, I gotta go.
Man, earlier we were in Uber together, Barry, and like, me
and Mimi were like, ah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
and you were like, Yeah, like, oh, I don't know about that
either.
He was like, oh my God.
I have a naturally loud voice.
No, I didn't notice while we were Ubering, while we were
Ubering, like you guys were in the backseat together and I
was in the front seat, right?
Because it was a smaller car.
And I was like, I can't hear these bitches.
And I were like, I was just like, what?
You're like, oh, I like your socks.
Oh, Miffy.
My Miffy socks.
Miffy.
When I went to Japan for the first time, I realized like how
many, like the endless possibility of showing socks.
I know.
I'm replacing every pair of my socks.
Yeah.
So these are all like, I have like seven Miffy pairs.
I love Miffy.
Tamagotchi pairs.
Did you see my Miffy bag in my bathroom?
I think I did.
It was cute.
Yeah.
Oh, did you ever find the Miffy bag you were looking for?
I did.
Ooh.
I think I did.
But okay, it has like this terrible part on the back that I
don't like.
that I didn't see.
Did it say something stupid in English?
No.
I don't want to say it because it's like really obvious, so.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know.
OK.
OK, now you guys do it.
Yes, yes, yes.
Loathing.
This is going to be like so much more put together.
Can I like show ourselves?
Yeah, they're going to, because they're like so serious
about this.
I know.
Wait, no.
Why don't you just paint yourselves green and pink, man?
I know.
Don't piss me off.
It's all in good fun.
You're pink.
Oh, whatever.
you're pink.
I'll do Glinda, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Where is it though?
Yes.
Did you hear that?
Guys, she's green.
Not me.
I'm blonde.
I'm literally blonde.
What are you saying to them?
Don't believe the lies.
Don't believe that my pit crew will tell you I'm
green-haired, but I don't have green hair.
I'm blonde.
Action!
Oh, your body.
I can have my pink and purple on my...
colors.
Wait, restart it, restart it.
I'll restart.
Oh, it's okay, okay, okay.
But of course I'll rise above it.
I don't know this part.
For I know that's how you'd want me to respond.
There's been so confusion for you to see my roommate is.
Unusually and exceedingly peculiar and altogether quite
impossible to do.
describe
Chinchilla Now do you guys do the choreography What is this
feeling so sudden and new I felt the moment I laid eyes on
you My pulse is rushing My head is reeling Yeah well my face
is flushing What is this feeling Fervid as a flame Does it
have a name yes loathing unadulterated loathing for your
face your voice your clothing let's just say I loathe it all
every little trait however small makes my very flesh begin
to crawl with simple other loathing it's the strong In such
total intestation It's so pure, it's so strong I don't know
who goes over there.
Oh, I do admit it came on fast Still, I do believe that it
can last And I will be loading, loading you my whole life.
I just can't go into you, I just do your good.
Never.
I do you, Shannon.
I don't think I could.
She's no Sarah, she's a starter.
We don't mean to show a bias.
But Galinda, you're a martyr.
Well, these things are sent to try us.
Oh, okay.
What the hell is walking now?
I know.
I know, what the hell?
Oh.
For Galinda, forced to reside with someone so disgusted if I
just want to tell you we're all on your side.
We share your love.
What is this feeling?
So sudden and new.
About the moment I laid eyes on you.
My pulse is rushing.
My head is reeling.
We love it all.
Oh, what is this feeling?
Does it have a name?
Yes.
Loading.
There's a strange exhilaration.
Total devastation!
Loading!
It's so pure and so strong!
Oh, I do admit it came on fast!
Still, I do believe that it can last!
And I will be loading more, forever loading, Truly, deeply
loading!
You!
My whole life long!
I'm happy to do this.
Boo!
Yay!
Did you hit your head on the table?
Did I?
I don't know.
I saw you like a little bit like.
I don't think so.
Okay, maybe I would have felt it.
Maybe I phased through it.
You're too focused on the song.
We're all under the maid cafe table now.
We're all under the maid cafe.
Yeah, we're all under the table.
Yeah, we're all under the maid cafe table.
We're on the floor, you guys.
This is kind of like humiliating.
Because...
Because, like, I make much weird faces.
I like, I like, oopalupa.
Me too, I've always like.
It's so awesome.
The audience doesn't see this.
We're, like, we have primetime view.
You can sing that one.
I would love that.
I don't know that song.
I don't know the whole thing.
Oopalupadupadidu?
I think it's just noises.
Is it not?
Yeah, it might be.
No, because they're also like, what do you get when you go
in chocolate?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get sucked up because then you will die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What?
the movie?
No, I think it's like, oh, no, the oopalupas show up when
somebody dies.
Yeah.
So that's why they say like, oh, what happens?
It's like their funeral song.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's like super dark, man.
Like, I saw it.
I saw it in like third grade.
Yeah, they die.
I don't remember this.
People die when they're... Do I know that, man?
The girl literally blows up into like a blue bag.
Oh, yeah, no, I don't know that.
Yeah.
Lily Wonka's got a body count, you guys.
ah we let him go get away with so many things because he's
like chocolate man is he like real life isn't there like a
real life Willy Wonka chocolate please I'm you this entire
weekend have been testing me what are you talking about no
that is a brand that is a brand you fucking bitch yeah
because I'm like the movie in the book that oh like a real
guy no I know he's not a real guy I was asking if the
chocolate brand was real that's you'd ask what do you mean i
fully thought you were like yeah but he's like a real man
who killed me no no why would i say that i meant these i'm
like he's a real guy be respectful willy wonka is a true
story guys wait till the next documentary comes out dude
you'll know you'll find out willy wonka aka i don't know
who's a chocolatier persie persie Hershey himself actually
being a Hershey Hershey Park is in Philadelphia.
Yeah, I want to go.
I want to go to the Hershey Park We should go We should go
we should go and we also have to go to uh, what is it?
It's in the Midwest It's like seasons.
No seasons world.
How holly world.
We gotta go to Hollywood.
We gotta go to Dollywood.
Yeah, we should oh my god I got a tick tock the other day.
I'm like, uh, it's like a bus tour that takes you to
different theme parks Like that's all they do and they cover
you like they do I saved it I'll send it to you Oh my god
that bus must be miserable though like the like all over Not
all over I think it's they only have the east coast right
now Oh yeah that's still like a little like you're on that
bus for hours You're not about that lifestyle okay just a
minute Oh okay sorry Theme park girl I gotta like third view
Okay no I'll go with theme parks Yeah We're the theme park
girls We're the theme park girls Yeah That was literally our
collab Oh Exactly.
No, no, no, no.
She wasn't.
That was before you were born.
Yeah, that was before you were born.
Yeah, yeah.
You hatched from an egg.
E-lid.
She's a mouse.
Mice do, I don't think.
Where are all your brothers and sisters?
No.
They got eaten by eagles.
Actually, don't mice eat their babies?
She probably ate them for sustenance.
Yeah, I ate them for sustenance.
Yeah.
The strongest.
It's why my ears are so big.
Oh, to hold your secrets.
No, because I ate.
To hold your secrets.
Yeah, because I eat them.
Me and girls are our friends.
I got that one.
Oh, I haven't seen that in so long.
Yeah, that was a Mean Girl.
You're so cultured.
That's awesome.
I made a Mean Girls reference the other day and they were
like, I got a comment and they were like, Mint is so old,
she's making me girl.
That time was!
I said, I said try, stop making fetch happen because about
six, seven, I was like stop trying to make fetch happen.
And they were like, oh, she's such a boomer referencing me.
Wait, no, that's like totally relevant.
Yeah, that's timeless.
Like excuse me.
All right, sing a Mean Girls musical song.
Is it timeless?
It is timeless.
everybody still knows Musical though I feel like I haven't
Hyun so long Well not Fetch, but like A Vetch Quoting Mean
Girls But like she doesn't even go here Yeah, that's what I
was like in her I feel like the fetch thing like fell out of
fashion though It was never a thing Don't think, your rage
being your rage being We're not talking about the phrase
fetch Like the word fetch No, no, no, no I'm saying it's
like quoting that specific part of the movie was like never
popular Wow He is trying to slander me on my own channel.
I invite you over for one time.
Blocked.
I don't know any of the Mean Girl musicals.
I know the one that people hated.
Whoa, they hated one.
Crazy and love.
Oh.
I don't want to get it.
You should learn the one where they go like.
You should learn the Halloween one.
Oh, yeah, because you said that it was the sexy mouse thing.
Yeah, the sexy mouse.
I rated you and so you, you like it.
I don't know.
It's like, I don't know any of the songs.
like so stupid.
It's a Karen song.
Yeah, it's a Karen song.
Yeah, because she dressed up as a mouse.
I'm a mouse.
Yeah, yeah.
I cure sexy cancer.
What?
Yeah, the whole song is just like a comedy routine.
That's silly.
I don't really like any of that.
I like it.
I take a guilty pleasure of mine.
That's fair.
I feel like this is like, never mind.
What do you mean?
It's like you guys are like, oh, Fetra's not really like
quoted.
And you and all the Mean Girls musical stuff and You guys
have an outdated quote?
No, it's because we're- It's like ourselves.
We're into cars.
It's a gap.
There's a gap.
There's a strong gap here.
What else do you guys want to sing?
I'm learning.
I don't think we know songs.
We just don't know the same songs.
I think we're all just brazen and we don't know.
Oh, so they got J-pop on that care of fun?
Yeah, J-pop, J-pop.
Yeah, they do.
Put on Gangnam Style.
I was Gangnam Styling back there.
Don't put on Gangnam Style.
No, no, no.
No!
Okay.
Here resident Korean girl.
Wait, I'm actually so bad though.
Now people are gonna know how bad I am at Korean.
Oh, they didn't know before.
Yeah, they didn't.
Really?
Wait, I didn't even know this song that well.
I was just, I just know the dance.
Oh, but Gangnam Style.
Gangnam Style.
Oh, my, oh, wait.
Oh, there's Korea on the bottom.
Guys, my eyesight.
My eyesight is so bad.
Get the binoculars.
Yeah, get the monocu- wait, I need my monoculars, right?
My monoculars!
I love you.
Oh
Get yourrams Can we get pause it?
I can't do it I can't do it Wait, wait, hold on hold on I
gotta do them Your Oh my god, she ripped it out
Oh my god She's swinging it around over her head.
I thought this was the same place.
I thought this was the same.
Okay, I'll take my bra off and solid there.
Yeah, I wasn't looking.
Whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Hey, seculate.
Whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hey.
Sexily lady.
Oh, oh, oh, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey.
We know what this is.
How does this break up?
What?
You can finally do it.
I don't know.
20 years old.
Anyone seeing this right now?
They're not making decisions.
They're not.
We were going home.
We're going to a gondola.
We're going to go in a gondola right now.
Layley.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, the gondola.
Hey, it's just escalating.
Oh, oh, oh, hey, hey, hey, hey.
This is reminding me, I have, and I say this with so much
love.
It's not about you guys.
I'm really, I'm so scared.
I've said this with so much love, and I appreciate
everybody's passion, but sometimes when I'm at, like, VTuber
events, it makes me giggle so much when people get, like,
super offbeat when they're, when they're, uh, wotang, and
they get, like, super offbeat, and it's, like, so
embarrassed.
and we're literally doing that now with the karaoke we're
the worst yeah we're like we're like doing it yeah we're
doing it why so this whoa it's a real girls party now i feel
like i think i was like half asleep i don't know she asked
me at like three in the morning we were like sharing a hotel
bed and she was like can i touch your your boobs and
apparently i said yes and then she didn't do it i i
chickened out because i was like i didn't expect to get this
far off guy tweeted about it and everybody was like you
should have done it you should have done it you should have
done it and i was like tweeted about how i sleep i'm just a
pervert i don't know what to say now we touch each other's
boobs and it's equal yeah she just touched my boob and i
just touched her boob yeah how did that make you feel um
well the thing is it's not really equal because she has a
bra on and i don't i mean i can take it off you guys have to
leave eventually yeah i know earlier barry was like i'm
getting comfy yeah i'm taking it up and it was like it was
It was on a starting screen and I was like, I hope nobody
can hear you like stripping.
No, no, it's just guys.
We're just getting out comfy.
No, I can re-wear it.
I just want to be.
I do have the other bed.
I don't know if you guys want to say.
Can a girl at her berries free?
Okay.
Your berries, my mimes, your mimes, your mimes, your mintos.
My mintos.
Your ashes, your tents.
Hey, what is with this?
Why are we just stopping at ashes?
What are we supposed to say?
Your ashes?
You're Marty's.
I know!
I just think that there's this implication that everybody
has boobs except me.
No, no, no, we weren't.
It's like the dead opposite!
I think you're the biggest here!
What?
Well, that's what I'm saying.
That's why I'm like, what the hell is going on?
The point was that it's like, hermento is my Mimi's
herberries.
Yeah, you don't have...
No, no, no, I get it.
Oh, I don't have a highly marketable name.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, no, we hate you.
That's my fucking name.
Wait, we hate you.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Why doesn't Ashton's work?
we say her ashes her Ashton's her Ashton's feels like kind
of wrong I don't know no you should do the the vocal stim
you guys were doing on the way over
They're like on their own brain wave right now like I really
crazy on the way here.
Mimi.
Me.
Minto.
You Mimi.
No, you Mimi.
Me.
Minto.
You with Mimi.
Yeah.
They love it.
Me.
Go gaga.
This is like when you put two toddlers together in your
first time.
Mimi.
Wow.
They're like doing the wave together.
Yeah, I mean, you're like interlocked fingers.
Oh my god.
Let me see how long we've been streaming before.
Because my clock is wrong.
Oh.
Do you guys want to do like one more song?
Sure.
Oh shit, has it already been?
Oh my god.
It's already been, yeah.
You guys gotta go home.
Guys, we can't.
I can't believe we can't believe we fucking did gum number.
style guys why do you get why do you pick that one of all we
need something that we can also say that's a joke yeah small
world what's something oh no it's never gonna happen lyrics
over and over again no it's in it's in like french oh oh
yeah because you you sing in korea and just now we're really
well it's because they couldn't see the lyrics oh guys you
know them that's oh that's why we messed up too because like
we couldn't see it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh do a
christmas song oh true yeah yeah yeah it's a christmas song
we could sing Maybe?
No.
That's yours.
Um.
So that's too like.
Thank you.
That's too sexy.
Hey.
That is kind of...
Actually has her whole shoulder out, man.
You have cute little like freckled shoulders.
Whoa!
Wait, I do too though.
That's the cancer, bro.
That's the cancer.
They're cute though.
Well, you got like freckly shoulders.
Yeah, don't look at my face.
I can't see unless I...
like you like really love i am really fam you that's so we
can't even go you fam i'm so fam i'm so pale i'm so fam now
we're thinking he's gene he's geese she's geese i'm not
doing it they're going off she's just like uh hey everyone
what's it what's it like a multiple person i mean last
christmas do you guys all know last yeah yeah what about all
they want for christmas to do Yeah, we can not hit a single
note.
Alright, everybody in chat also type out the word, so it's
like we're all singing.
Yeah, we're all together!
Let's all sing together.
I feel like last Christmas is too sad.
It is, but there's the best part where it's like...
Oh, I'm forgetting it now.
Twice.
She's been doing this multiple times.
You're just like, guys, let's go back to this topic.
And now...
I forgot.
I'm sorry!
She was like, we were like in the room and she goes, And
also...
And she's like, I don't remember.
and it feels bad because then people were like oh wait no
like it's fine like we could change the topic and you're
like i really don't know i genuinely forgot guys i don't
think this has no relation i'm using caravan imagine it did
if it does i might scream no it doesn't have it every wham
song has that like moment where it's like where it goes wham
oh i wish that we could lose this crowd that's not last
christmas no i know but i'm saying Wham song.
Is that even?
Is that Wham?
That's not Wham.
It is.
Isn't it Wham?
You guys aren't gonna out Wham.
No, that's George Costanza or something.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
That's a guy from the Seinfeld.
No, no, no.
I'm a retro Vtuber.
That's George Michael who is in Wham.
Yeah, but it's not Wham.
It's George Michael.
Oh my god.
They sound exactly alike.
Well, it's the same guy.
So yeah.
But it's not the same music.
But you took him out the, you took him out the, out the
Wham.
he's not in the wham wait how many people are in wham four
it's like a band it's w-h-a-m it might be an owl city thing
michael william andy uh william afton it's been so long
since i said the man behind the slaughter wham is two guys
oh we'll see my bad i just i i'll be honest i just lied and
said four because i was like most people have four i thought
the name was each letter of their name that would make sense
let's do secret of the mimic don't laugh that's a genuine
that's a genuine suggestion why did she just break it up so
casually I'm trying to like sneak it in I'm trying to slide
in that I really want to sneak secret of the mimic right now
oh my gosh and it's
I'll just get it on Or Sabrina Carpenter My name is the
fucking baby Oh yeah We are not gonna sing Secret of the
Mavic As a live song We're not Okay I don't know it at all
Wait I think We all know all the words I feel like I know
every single word My name is Jackie And I'm fucking Becky I
love this song You gotta listen to it man It's so good I
also never heard this What Secret of the Mavic Yeah It's
like a It's like a family Yeah I think I've heard it once
but I don't know it like it's like so I thought I knew it
and then I saw you two sing it and I was like I don't know
it's not part of the song would you were just singing yeah
my name is Jackie and I'm fucking Becky what yeah I was like
I thought I knew this is this a DEMPA song it sounds like it
does a good job I think it is DEMPA song like it changes
like singers like multiple times well it's it's just like
one guy but he's like changing the pitch of his like you
don't believe wait do you guys know the Golden Freddy like
brain rap rap thing I'm Golden Freddy, I like to scare And
when I scare, I become a nightmare You're in the office,
probably gonna die And when you will die, cause you're not
alive I'm Golden Freddy, and I'm a robot And when I kill
you, you become a robot Holy shit, bars She's not a rapper
though Why did I say it with that voice the whole time?
holy fuck i'm getting into it i was really into it um let's
do a christmas song yeah let's do it like this do you want
to do last christmas we can do okay we'll do last okay we'll
do i really don't have to i'm i'll be like george and the
other guy george and the other guy it'd be like stacked ups
yeah yeah you kind of offended me when you were that's not a
way i'm tall like like wait how tall are you like i'm five
seven oh seriously okay so three of us stacked on top of
each other's shoulders we'll be one first we'll be other
doors yeah yeah we'll be other doors yeah because i'm
fucking big i'm all in here okay i didn't say that it's kind
of you're so tall i'm so jealous i'm so jealous
my heart but the very next day you gave it away oh yes here
just gave me from tears I'll give it to you so I was special
special and my heart but the very next day it hurts she's
punching me she's punching me I'm serious about tears I'll
give you a little bit of my You gave it away!
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I love that.
What?
Why is everyone punching me?
I sit in and twine shy.
I keep my distance, but you still catch my eye.
Tell me, baby, do you recognize me?
Well, it's been a year.
It doesn't surprise me.
Christmas.
I've never been said, didn't I?
Don't say I love you.
I went to- Oh, I've been, but if you kiss me now, I know
you'd fool me again.
Kiss, kiss!
Oh my god!
I realize everybody's getting whammed right now.
Yeah.
Whammed?
It's like a thing.
I hear what it is.
What is getting whammed?
Where'd we get it?
Yeah, where'd we get it?
Is that a kidded wammed?
There is that kidd.
I got you.
It's so special.
Wait, what is that?
You don't know what I'm against?
In my heart.
You can't listen to the song until like after Christmas.
Oh, why?
It's so cute.
It's like I'm a baby.
That's like something you do in like middle school.
That's an old man challenge.
I told this in my chat and they were like, I've never heard
of that.
I don't know where to
be with.
My dad, my dad kid in one house.
I'm hiding from you.
So I thought I thought you were someone to rely on me.
I guess I was a shoulder.
I thought we were trying to get out.
What?
What is wrong with you?
I like your song a lot.
I love it.
Happy Christmas.
I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
Oh, my bad.
You gave me from tears.
I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the whole...
Oh, my bad.
You gave me away.
I'll give it to someone special.
Special.
Yeah.
You said that was this like iconic George, like the iconic
name George.
I forgot his last name.
It's like a break.
Wow, he's good.
Wow,
wow, wow.
This is a classic.
I don't know why, but I've also been thinking about the
anime working recently.
Yeah, right?
It like disappeared.
It was so popular and then like disappeared out the face of
the fan.
It was so cool.
I know, it was like such a big thing for a while.
Yeah, it was huge.
And then I feel like, you did your anime review recently.
Yeah.
I almost submitted it, but I was afraid you were gonna like,
oh my gosh.
Well, that was the breaks.
No sympathy.
I know, that's why.
I was like, I can't do it, she wouldn't even be nice.
Wait, let's list a few.
Oh yeah, wait, yeah, that's weird.
Oh gosh, I had the picture.
I put, oh my gosh, why am I blanking?
I put you two marshmallows on the sheet.
Oh.
Yeah, I would make fun of you.
Which one?
It's so good!
Wait, what?
Which one?
It's not about Ichigo Marshmallow.
It's about the presence of Ichigo Marshmallow in the
presence of other shows.
Like what?
Um, Kitamari Sketch, Donon Biori.
Yeah, I feel like it deserves to be in there.
I put Ichigo Marshmallow.
I put Odd Taxi, which is a more recent one.
Oh, Odd Taxi.
I hope it's like a Nepuni.
Oh, yeah.
I put, oh my gosh, I put Stupid, but I can't relate right
now.
I was pretty nice this time.
No, but I was like, I don't want to make it.
Well, no, it's just, it's like I said, it's not really a
rose so much as like, you know, you must know what, what
this looks like.
When Sony puts Ichigo Marshmallow and Nonon Biori and
Hidomori's dead.
Well, I didn't put all that.
Put all your words in my mouth.
I literally just said that I'm just saying that it's about
Ichigo Marshmallow among the presence of other other ones.
That would cause me to be like, I know what you are.
about this one did I I think I stopped by that stream that
you did and then I was like I think I said like Jujutsu
Kaisen and you just like rolled your eyes at me yeah yeah
see we both can't submit mine's like I know cute things and
then you get shown in slop yeah I know it's slop I just like
it carrying around my plushies like I mean I'm a proponent
of like you don't even need to admit it slop I think you
know what you just like yeah I mean I just mainly consume I
think it's like bad shonen though to be totally honest like
i think it's like jjk so popular i mean i'm just like a i
mean and we're talking about this like i'm just like a say
you pervert yeah oh yeah yeah that's wait why did you guys
say it like that no that's honestly that's honestly no but
the cute girls doing cute things anime category is literally
also for say you perverts that's true that's yeah but the
other side yeah yeah yeah they just grab like that's so
funny i've watched so many just because somebody yeah yeah
yeah yeah i watched uh that really like one really like
messed up not messed up but like really weird show her anime
that was like what is it wolf prince and like the girl who
like lies so much yeah i know what you're talking about
abusive towards her the wolf prince yeah yeah yeah i watched
that i was like i kind of like it can we delete this mod i
don't think disney or the hershey company or willy wonka are
gonna let this live so it's probably mr my channel is my
channel's nuked
anyways coming after us oh too everybody yeah this is like
too late we're tired see you It's been like an hour.
Has it been an hour?
Yeah, it's been an hour.
I feel like it's been like two minutes.
What?
I'm missing.
I wrestled you guys.
Oh, you want to wrestle her?
No!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh my god!
She told me!
Wait, don't like, don't like choke her!
Whoa!
I have to be fragile with you.
I got wrestled!
Oh my god, tussled.
Oh my god.
Do it again.
I know, it kind of feels good.
Like, actually.
Okay.
You kind of like the, like the, you like, you want to be
hugging so bad.
I do.
They're so touched on.
Like, oh.
Do you guys ever, when you, like, were a kid and I went to
the pool and wanted someone to, like, throw you into the
water?
Yeah.
That's what it feels about, like, being thrown into the bed.
I had, like, my, my family friend, my parents' family
friends, like, the adult When we were all in the water
together, he would like launch all the kids.
Like 10 feet out of the water.
It was awesome.
Me too.
Okay, thank you everybody.
Okay, thank you.
Bye.
Thank you.
O2.
O2, everybody.
I'm like, I'm like out of, I gotta wear my bra.
I was gonna say any last word.
Okay.
That's sad.
That's the last word.
Okay, we all gotta put up.
No, wait, don't make that last word.
I thought you walking up with your bra.
It's because I panicked!
What do you want me to do?
We're all girls here!